this to me I thought was the most
interesting an Apple card engraved with
your name on with the Apple logo made
out of titanium I mean that's like a
hundred percent of people want to pull
that out right I want that I think they
got this from the fire festival festival
documentary company right your car it's
true he was doing good pole PT I just
came absolutely it's great for a minute
or two that's great for crushing
pharmaceuticals according to the fry
festival if you have adderall and you
want to chop it up it's perfect I'm
making that up I don't know the fry
festival founder is on adderall and
chopping it up with his metal titanium
car I think we know I think a great
product right like it seems like 2% cash
back on everything was my understanding
yep no fees no predatory interest if
you're late yeah they're gonna present
everything in a non confusing Apple way
so I think if you're you know you're
getting your first credit card you've
already got an iPhone they've got this
audience to advertise it to you that's
great I mean I'm just a mercenary for
cash back yeah so I got 2% cash back but
I think Apple it's you know everybody's
always switching it up on yeah yeah yeah
that number doesn't seem that impressive
to me and I use it yeah I use the Amazon
card and that's 5% on Amazon purchases
which feels like an increasingly large
amount of my purchases you know I wish
wait you get 5% back on the Amazon card
yeah I do where you been what yeah all
right stop the show probably can get
that really I'm surprised Apple didn't
say we'll give you 10% back on Apple
purchases or at least three or four
cents yes because I buy my stuff on
Amazon now if I'm gonna buy something
digital I mean I it on Amazon it's a
little bit more portable but if it was
10% cheaper on Apple I think pretty hard
about buying it there so ya know it's a
great it seems like a great product as
is but I think a [ __ ] take or take the
card and get one of our services like
Apple News plus for free or half off see
that's what I continue getting if you
spend a certain amount on the card it
bundles your news Plus and your music so
if you spend over a thousand dollars a
year on the card you get the bundle of
services free or something but I could
see this being gigantic like
honestly that looks like like a
corporate ID badge to me it does
actually the chip reader in it but I
mean everybody's gonna be a bank now
yeah well makes sense it's mean they
have a pile of money this is a great way
to spend it
it'll be a bank